mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
manche familien geschichten beginnen wie
im märchen und enden tragisch dafür
steht die familie gucci wie keine andere
jetzt im kino mit lady gaga in der
hauptrolle
das unglück in der gucci familie wurzelt
in denen die von grund auf böse sind
macht und privilegien
pauli ist nicht immer spaßig weiß auch
darsteller jared leto
familie kann die hölle sein
das gilt auch für die familie der
nacktmull auch bei bremen muss der
nachwuchs leiden im zoo zürich schauen
wir wie es bei den tieren so
funktioniert mit den familienbanden
[Musik]
der tango
wir haben wir machen heute station im
zoo zürich und von hier aus wollen wir
herausfinden wie sie denn aussehen kann
die familie beim menschen und bei tieren
wir kommen auf dem kulturplatz zum
beispiel die flamingos hinter mir sie
leben in kolonien und sie leben serielle
monogamie wie das aber bei den elefanten
bei den pavianen oder bei den
königspinguinen aussieht das schauen wir
uns gleich an und wir sprechen mit dem
neuen zoodirektor
[Musik]
si
ja die königspinguine sie sind ein
leuchtendes beispiel für gelebte
gleichberechtigung mann und frau also
vater und mutter teilen sich die pflege
aber selbst in dieser idylle kann es
auch mal vorkommen dass da die eine oder
andere intrige vonstatten geht nämlich
dann wenn zum beispiel ein männerpaar
ein junges haben möchte dort kann es
schon mal vorkommen dass da ein fremdes
geklaut
aber das ist ziemlich harmlos im
vergleich dazu was sich vor einigen
jahren in einer menschen familie
abspielte
die familie hinter der mode imperium
gucci ist eine geschichte um gier macht
und mord und dieser ware krimi kommt
jetzt unter dem titel haus auf gut in
unsere kinos in der hauptrolle lady gaga
so kennen wir die lady glamourös und und
ein bisschen gaga an der weltpremiere in
london zog der star von house of gucci
alle blicke auf sich und den neid seiner
prominenten schauspiel brüder und
schwestern ebenfalls
im film geht es um die leiden der
schillernden fashion familie
das war ein name dessen klang so
lieblich war so verführerisch
ein synonym für reichtum die macht
aber der name war auch ein fluch
muss es wissen schließlich trug sie nach
der hochzeit mit maurizio gucci selbst
diesen namen bevor die scheidung alles
zunichte machte der rest ist schnell
erzählt der familienzwist gipfelte am 27
märz 1995 in mauritius ermordung im
auftrag seiner tief gekränkten ehefrau
patrizia reggiani wie sie später
herausstellen sollte
die vermeintliche traum familie mit
süßer tochter und wohlhabender
verwandtschaft hat er sich als trugbild
entpuppt
laut tolstoi gleichen alle glücklichen
familien einander doch jede unglückliche
familie ist auf eigene weise unglücklich
wie würden sie das unglück der gucci
familie beschreiben
[Musik]
das unglück in der gute familie wurzelt
in dingen die von grund auf böse sind
macht und privilegien
das streben nach reichtum und macht
machte die familie blind
darum konnte maurizio unbemerkt ermordet
weil sich alle so sehr aufs geschäft
konzentrierten dass ihnen entging was
patricia tat
doch alles der reihe nach gegründet
wurde das italienische
familienunternehmen von gucci
der übergab das geschäft seinen
tüchtigsten kinder alte und rodolfo die
im film von bettina und die einst
verkörpert werden
letztgenannter verstand sich als mode
könig der seinen sohn maurizio zum
thronfolger machen wollte dieser
wiederum fühlte sich eingeengt
vollrath adam driver in der analyse
seiner figur
[Musik]
mauritius vater rodolfo kontrollierte
jede seiner entscheidungen mit wem
ausging wo er dinierte und wann er
wieder zu hause sein
er war nicht gewohnt selbst zu
entscheiden und dann starb sein vater
nicht einmal die entscheidung das
familiengeschäft zu übernehmen traf er
seine neue freundin patricia tat das mit
großer begeisterung für ihn
die modewelt hatte es patrizia reggiani
die arme aufgewachsen war früh angetan
maurizio gucci angelte sie sich wohl
weil er der spross einer
prestigeträchtigen familie war zu der
sie auch gehören wollte das gefühl ein
vollwertiges familienmitglied zu sein
wurde ihr aber verwehrt sogar vom
eigenen mann das ist ernst du lachst
einfach es steht nur mein name auf den
becher nicht deiner
patricia status ist von anfang an
bedeutend tiefer als derjenige der
coaches sie versucht alles und gleich zu
ziehen ohne erfolg
er war nie so schillernd traf nie dem
rechten ton
apropos sucht man auf youtube nach
videos der society-lady findet sich so
manch harte aussage bestätigt wie status
verliebt patrizia reggiani war
[Musik]
es ist viel besser geld als kein geld so
weit
ich weine lieber in einem rolls royce
als glücklich auf einem fahrrad zu
sitzen so viel ist klar
um ihre stellung im hause gucci zu
verbessern waren patricia alle mittel
recht so trieb sie ihren schwager paulo
zu einer eigenen linie weil sie ahnte
dass der von verwandlungskünstler jared
leto gespielte underdog scheitern würde
mich fasziniert dass es sich in gewisser
hinsicht um eine archetypische familie
hat und gleichzeitig um ein
extrembeispiel dass alle grenzen sprengt
die budgets schufen ein imperium und
taten sich gleichzeitig die
schrecklichsten gingen sie zogen
gegeneinander in den krieg
er sagt also dass die eigene familie die
halle saale richtig
der familie kann die reinste hölle seien
absolut nicht jede familie ist gesund
ich würde nicht einmal sagen dass wir
uns alle auf familienwerte einigen
können
trotzdem glaube ich dass es auch viel
liebe gab in dieser familie die gucci
story bezog sie verklagten sich sie
hassten sich sie schrieben sich
gegenseitig an und dann erschienen sie
alle lachen zum abendessen wo sie sich
küssten und umarmten sie waren einfach
ein wilder haufen
beim vater sohn und
ich habe viel darüber recherchiert was
war die zum patricia liebte es war ihre
stärke in ihrer beziehung gab sie ihm
ratschläge wie ihr das geschäft führen
und sein potenzial voll ausreizen kann
obwohl er zunächst nichts vom familien
business wissen wollte sie inspirierte
ihn die zügel bei gucci in die eigenen
hände zu nehmen
es ist zeit ballast loszuwerden
also und paul sind
sie sind eine zumutung für das
unternehmen und alle wissen dass sie
müssen gehen
und du musst deine verdammte firma in
den griff kriegen
patricia
das ist meine familie
das bin ich auch ja ja die liebe familie
wer sich haus auf die an schaut fühlt
sich in der eigenen sippe gleich ein
bisschen mehr zu hause und findet die 18
jährigen eigenen verwandten gleich viel
weniger verrückt
wir haben alle unsere verrückten
familiengeschichten darum können wir
vieles nachvollziehen zugleich stellt
ist ein juristisches vergnügen da einer
familie zuzuschauen die noch verrückter
ist als die alten
wenn auch ganz schön böse
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir machen jetzt im elefantenhaus
stationen und hier treffe ich den neuen
zoodirektor severin dresen jetzt sind
wir bei den elefanten habe ich schon
gelernt da gehen ja die frauen den ton
an wie funktioniert das genau ja wenn
elefanten da haben wir das so genannte
material das heißt es gibt immer eine
quasi chefin in der gruppe und alle
anderen tiere in der gruppe sind
meistens mit ihr verwandt das sind also
entweder die schwestern oder die töchter
oder die next generation und sie gibt
also den ton an sie entscheidet wo es
lang geht auch ganz praktisch also sie
weiß zum beispiel in der natur wo ist
das wasserloch wo ist das gute essen sie
ist also in jeder hinsicht die chef
gefällt mir gut dieses konzept ja es ist
sehr modern
wo sind denn die männer wo sind die
bullen die bullen sind erst mal als
junge tiere in der gruppe klar und dann
irgendwann werden sie alt wenn sie also
wenn sie so meistens mit 8 kurz davor
werden geschlechtsreif zu werden dann
werden sie aus der gruppe verstoßen das
heißt die böden sind einzelgänger wollen
sie ein einziger gibt euch auch mal
knatsch in der elefantenherde also jener
frauen herde muss man ja sagen ja
insbesondere zwischen den anderen
gruppen teilnehmerinnen quasi oder
gruppen mitgliederinnen weil natürlich
da gibt es auch eine hierarchie also es
gibt zwar die chefin aber auch darunter
gibt es eine hierarchie und die ist
natürlich nicht so fix da kann man immer
mal wieder so als heranwachsende
elefantenkuh auch mal ausprobieren
kriege ich mich da ein bisschen höher
positioniert werden die konflikte gelöst
ist unter den elefanten
grundsätzlich erstmal erst mal
körperlich natürlich wird am anfang
schon erstmal ein bisschen gedroht
beziehungsweise es gibt auch natürlich
innerhalb der verwandtschaft weißmann
sowie dem stehe ich am nächsten die
eigene mutter ist tendenziell ja er mir
zugeneigt als vielleicht eine tante und
cousine
aber dann wird das zum teil auch
wirklich körperlich ausgetragen und das
ist natürlich bei so weise wuchtigen
tieren mit einer gewissen masse sieht
das dann für uns sehr eindrücklich aus
die tiere verletzten sich aber
eigentlich nie schwer
waren hier werden ganz großen tiere
gehen wir weiter zu den ganz kleinen
[Musik]
so hatte
nein
[Musik]
hier bei den nacktmullen ganz kleine
tierchen aus den schönheitspreis muss ja
gestehen gewinnen sie nicht und trotzdem
sind sie ihr spezialgebiet weshalb also
die schönheit liegt im auge des
betrachters bzw auch die inneren werte
zählen
sicherlich nicht ich würde sogar sagen
hässlich aber sie haben eine ganz
spannende biologie und auch eine ganz
spannende
sozialstruktur also die nackten mode
sind tatsächlich die einzigen säugetiere
von denen wir wissen dass sie ein ein
system haben wie die bienen es gibt also
eine königin und sie ist die chefin von
allen ich habe hier in diesem kontext
das wort so sozial gelernt das bedeutet
es gibt quasi also diese diese chefin es
gibt die königin und dann sind
eigentlich alle ja mit ihr verwandt also
die produziert zum teil hunderte
nachkommen und sie muss dafür sorgen
dass
sie keine rivalin und bekommt und
deswegen die stresst ihre töchter
chronisch das heißt die stresst ihre
töchter so sehr dass sie nicht
geschlechtsreif werden und deswegen hat
sie quasi automatisch gibt es keine
weitere königin sein totales system ja
das so ist so ist die natur das nur wer
nur wenn sie das schafft kann sie
weiterhin können bleiben für sehr
spannen lässt habe ist dass ihr
spezialgebiet weil es eben so
interessant ist also ich hab einfach
einfach eine große großen fable für so
die underdogs und ich bin gerade hier in
der nähe war man hat diese unglaublich
anmutigen giraffen man hat die
beeindruckende nasen ohren da finde ich
es gut wenn man auch so ein land zu
bricht für für die kleinen hässlichen
tiere die aber häufig eine ganz
spannende biologie dahinter haben was
ist ihre ansicht was können wir familien
wir menschen lernen von den tieren also
ich glaube was man im tierreich
wunderbar sehen kann das ist eine
unglaubliche fülle von unterschiedlichen
familienstrukturen gibt und dass ihr
alle irgendwie funktionieren und ich
denke das kann man ja so als halte
botschaft auch für uns nehmen für uns
als gesellschaft es gibt eine große
fülle an ganz unterschiedlichen
familienstrukturen und alle können gut
funktionieren danke für dieses gespräch
danke
[Musik]
wir sehen eine
junge schweizerin wird welt dagegen die
tradition ihres elternhauses eine solche
schlagzeile könnte über den bisherigen
schaffen der sängerin prix arago stehen
die st gallerin mit srilankesische
wurzeln ist ein shooting star mit
enormem potenzial
mein kollege nino gadient hat pädagoge
ist dann kurz vor ihrem konzert treffen
können
brüssel london new york und reputation
der situation aktuell ist oder wo und
wie sie noch weil es da aber jeder
faktor ist gar nicht begeistert von der
idee positiv auf die große bühne der
welt und sie ist sein job hat das
magdeburger vergrößern ich treffe
piraten kurz vor der show im zürcher
club exil zwischen grober und garderobe
ja
[Musik]
der familie war sehr musikalisch ist in
fachlich sehr musikalisch und trotzdem
eher langsam vom mitwählen dass du so
große
kunde hat das darf ich sogar
zukunftsmusik aber
[Musik]
warum will ich denke den verkehr schon
zu stark freut oder wenn ja einfach die
nachtleben und alkohol rauchen
ja ich mir
nix damit zu hause bleiben der akku ist
durchgestartet vor allem mit ihrem song
chol auf die bbc entdeckte und spielst
musik die ostschweizerin und die fifa
verwendet das lied als soundtrack für
ein berühmtes fußball geben
aber eigentlich hat es nur solche
entscheide moment boni mir selber haben
das talent und ich musste was gemacht
[Musik]
eur vj nennen sie ihren musikstil sie
mischt elemente aus sri lanka mit dem
zusammen was der top und army kosmos so
hergibt
[Musik]
schon als kind spielte geige mit sieben
musiziert fiel in der familie zusammen
mit ihrem bruder und dem vater
[Musik]
auf der internationalen bühne unterwegs
ich weiß nicht so
sauber sekunde und dann ist da ja
also redet jetzt nicht groß über die
sache was da passiert ist erst mal und
dich gut aber
wir bestehen
[Musik]
die musik ist trotzdem eben wie ein
family business pädagoge ist immer mit
ihr auf der bühne happened am keyboard
er ist produzent vertrauter und
wichtigster musikalischer partner und
die beiden scheiben noch die songs
zusammen
ja na ja irgendwie buch ist sowieso
minarette space zum kreativ und er
schiebt man speed oder idee und text
[Musik]
die zeitung
die ehemalige buchhalterin muss sie sich
durchsetzen emanzipieren von der
traditionellen familie um ganz auf die
musik setzen zu können
was bedeutet die familie hat
familie
alles also
ich wäre wichtig immer in alles was
[Musik]
könnte ich spiele das ist
wirklich ein intensiver kontakt
cor ag startet gerade die große karriere
und zugleich angekommen ganz bei sich
[Musik]
mit
diese paviane habe ich eben gelernt
heißen keller das und sie leben im hare
im auto ein männchen mit ganz vielen
weibchen diese lebensform kann ich mir
vorstellen ist für die menschen familie
im neuen roman von johnson franzen
hingegen gar keine option
crossroads man könnte das mit scheide
wegen übersetzen es ist der neue
familien roman des amerikanischen star
autors johnson frenzel der autor zeigt
eine familie an entscheidenden
lebenspunkten was macht eine familie aus
welche werte und normen hat sie fragen
die der roman aufwirft
ich schreibe eigentlich keine bücher
über themen ich war einfach fasziniert
von der idee menschen darzustellen für
die er glaube sehr wichtig ist auf so
etwas zu kommen das war eine sache von
fünf minuten die fünf charaktere zu
entwickeln das war eine arbeit von zwei
jahren
die geschichte spielt im amerika der
70er jahre mit richard nixon an der
macht und einer generation von
nachkriegs bohmann die versucht sich von
den kriegstraumata ihrer eltern
loszulösen es ist eine ära voller
schwung freiheitsdrang und des sexuellen
aufbruchs
der roman folgt den familienmitgliedern
an einem tag vor weihnachten
1971 in einer fiktiven vorstadt von
chicago
roger hildebrand vater von vier kindern
ist pfarrer seine ehe ist längst brüchig
geworden er fühlt sich eingezwängt
zwischen zwanghafter religiosität und
erotischen sehnsüchten der
schriftsteller und literaturkritiker
philipp tingler schätzt genau diese
alltäglichkeit der handlungen und den
familienkonflikten die jeder aus seinem
leben kennt
also die familie hildebrand um die es in
dem roman crossroads von john von
grenzen geht ist eigentlich eine für
ihre zeit als typisch angelegte familie
dieses dieses buches unter anderem
deshalb faszinierend weil es das projekt
unternimmt wieder mal universelle
geschichten zu erzählen universelle
konflikte diese großen themen
generationenkonflikte auch geschwister
konflikte insofern ist die familie in
vielerlei beziehung
typisch und in mancher beziehung auch
nicht im roman bringt jedes
familienmitglied darum ein guter mensch
zu sein und scheitert der älteste sohn
hadert auf dem college damit sich als
privilegierter weißer vor dem hit am
krieg gedrückt zu haben
also schmeißt er sein studium und meldet
sich zum militär
die mutter hatte sich vor ihrer ehe mit
einem verheirateten mann eingelassen
wurde schwanger trieb ab und wandte sich
um buße zu tun einem fundamentalen
katholischen glauben zu
und beck in die schöne tochter ist
kokett und selbstverliebt am ende droht
der zweitjüngste sohn die komplette
familie in den abgrund zu ziehen
es gibt viele drogen in crossroads ich
war ein sehr brave junge ich habe keine
genommen es gibt trinkerei und sex ich
habe nichts davon gemacht ich war nicht
cool aber im buch sind viele coole typen
und das war meine einführung in das was
ich einen kampf für soziale
gerechtigkeit nennen würde
einen inneren kampf führt auch vater
hildebrand der stark von den werten
seiner kirchengemeinschaft geprägt ist
mal will er ein guter christ sein setzt
sich für minderheiten einmal versucht er
eine junge witwe zu erobern was dabei
auf der strecke bleibt ist die eigene
familie das heißt die moralischen
konflikte die grenzen hier schildert
auch als familienkonflikte sind durch
diese verlagerung in die jüngere
vergangenheit werden die einen ein
bisschen pointierte es ist leichter
moralische oder ethische fragen im
rahmen der 70er jahre als historische
epoche zu klären moral und religion in
den 70er jahren wichtige richtwerte
durch die sexuelle revolution werden sie
plötzlich in frage gestellt die
protagonisten geraten in ein dilemma
zwischen freiheits wunsch und
gesellschaftliche normen bin ich ein
guter oder schlechter mensch
menschen haben etwas schmutziges an sich
etwas verschmutzen dass du selbst fühlst
dich vielleicht als guter mensch aber du
bist immer auch teil einer größeren
struktur und die macht dich schuldig
schuldgefühle plagen im roman alle
philipp winkler aber findet moral ist
damals wie auch heute
überbewertet
ich glaube
benutzt diese diese diesen komplex der
moral und auch der religion um einfach
einen grundlegenden konflikt zu
illustrieren nämlich diese diese
grundlegende spannung die jeder und jede
von uns kennt zwischen der verpflichtung
einer gemeinschaft einer familie normen
gegenüber und dem eigenen individuellen
streben die figuren im roman zeichnet
sich durch ihr gefühls dilemma aus diese
ambivalenz kennen vermutlich viele und
trotzdem kämpft jedes familienmitglied
für sich im stillen
also das sind im kern typische
familienkonflikte die jede die das was
familie ist und ausmacht und die mehr
oder weniger in jeder familie vorkommen
und dass das typische ist zugleich das
besondere daran und deswegen
schätze ich dieses buch weil es dieses
konzept von literatur aufnehmen und was
sagt uns der roman über familien heute
vielleicht soviel keiner ist perfekt
jede hat ihre eigene dynamik ihre
eigenen werte tradition und doch
bedeutet familie auch verbundenheit das
macht uns fremden mit seinem
familienepos klar übrigens es ist der
erste band einer trilogie
[Musik]
löning
allemal
mai
ist louis
[Musik]
die daumen
hier zum schluss sind wir noch bei den
galapagos schildkröten uralt können sie
werden wer weiß vielleicht deshalb weil
sie wenig stress mit ihrem nachwuchs
haben die weibchen vergraben ihre eier
und das war es dann auch mit der
brutpflege am nächsten mittwoch bleiben
wir nahe an der familie und beschäftigen
uns mit erben und mit mike müller und
seinem neuesten bühnenstück und gleich
jetzt geht es weiter mit der sternstunde
philosophie und der autorin leila
slimani eine gute woche für sie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wien
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen ihr kultur ist
es los
[Musik]